[Music]
welcome to another episode of what's a
Prof hi Walter good day Martin we're
almost at the end of the year I'm very
pleased to hear it but we're heading
towards
2024 that's going to be exciting
25 will be even more exciting I think
we're heading for very interesting times
and we've got an interesting topic again
because people just don't seem to get it
no they don't get it let's
pray our heavenly
father it is a privilege to work for you
and we thank you that we can be here and
we ask that you please lead through this
discussion that the truth can come to
the four and that you will guide our
minds with the Holy Spirit and in show
us what you want us to give to the
people in Jesus name amen
amen so the title is is the cbdc the
mark of the beast that's the Central
Central Bank digital currency there are
so many people that believe
that now the mark of the beast has to do
with worship doesn't it it does let me
just say that in the how many times have
we had to do the mark of the beast we've
done it at noria and still people don't
want to accept it they all say it is the
Central Bank digital currency the
barcode you name it whatever it is the
best the vaccine was the mark of the
beast at one stage everything but it
they never come to the true Mark well
the only one who can Define the mark of
the beast is the Beast and the Beast has
pertinently said what it is we'll come
to that as we go along now
Martin
prophecy is history written in advance
isn't it yeah does the devil have a
counterfeit prophecy yes it's called
it's called
planning yeah yeah it's called planning
it's writing a script and then sticking
to the script and calling it prophecy
and then if anybody um shows it out
that's
conspiracy oh that's a conspiracy are
you a conspiracy theorist Martin I
believe according to their definition
yes but the whole Bible is a conspiracy
theory that's if you read the book of
Daniel that's the greatest conspiracy
ever written that's a problem there is a
conspiracy going on and you know what
the conspiracy was
uncovered the Reformation took away the
veil and showed exactly who's behind the
conspiracy yeah and they've pulled the
wall over everybody's eyes again and put
the veil back yeah true plus wool over
the eyes so that they never will see
again so the world is really without an
excuse Martin let's look at the devil's
history written in
advance this is the cover of The
Economist of 2012
now they have this propensity to show
their planning for the next years
Etc and they do it quite well they're
like The
Simpsons very um accurate predictions
yes and of course the economist is comes
out under the flag of the
Rothchilds who happen to be the Vatican
Bankers in case people don't know what
it is they can look it up in the
Catholic Andy
cyclopedia they are the RO Shields the
red
shields looking after the money that's
what the Roman army used to wear and go
to war with now we don't want to go into
any great detail with this cover and uh
talk about all the intricacies about it
but something is very fascinating Martin
if you look at the top here you see a
Hamas terrorist over there the hang
glider is that correct Martin that's
correct and then there is a big boom in
the middle
here and there is Israel also with a
hang
glider
uh tell us what happened there Martin
yeah didn't we say that we think this
was planned in any case well we said
that in a previous one but if you say
something like that you get into trouble
these days don't you no you can even be
labeled anti-semitic if you want to say
it if you are against Zionism which is
basically just a political
ideology then you are also labeled an
anti-semitic these days but let's put it
quite categorically we are not anti-
anyone no neither are we anti-semitic
nor are we
anti-islamist we're anti nobody but
we're pro truuth and if those
organizations do not have the truth
because Jesus is the way the truth and
the life then unfortunately we have to
show that it's not biblical true soan
here in
2012 in this
picture they show a conflict between
Israel and
Hamas and they're using hand gliders did
it happen
yes motorized ones huh they used
motorized motorized ones isn't that
amazing and then you have all kinds of
interesting pictures that we're not
going to go into but it looks like the
devil is very busy MH and uh that the
political systems are very busy and of
course here we have climate change of
course and the one who's orchestrating
everything is the devil well they got
that right they got that right
but who does the devil give his power to
and great authority to image of the
Beast okay and in the meantime you have
Simon cow over here keeping people
occupied with theater and
activity so that they don't really see
what's going on behind his back yeah
which is all this nonsense over here we
have all the conflicts with you know
kimyong un and Putin and everybody here
in a pool of fire and you have economic
factors and then you have the hackers
over here like cyber attacks and cyber
attacks and they're facing in the right
direction yeah they're looking at what's
happening in the world right you have
this train and on this train you have
the banking system the central banking
system and there you have the devil
pushing it along they've got that right
yeah they've got that right
absolutely and we don't want to go into
all the details but it looks like uh
gluttony for oil is a major problem and
the biggest problem is the United States
of America when it comes to being a
glutton for fossil fuels so climate
change is very important we need
conflicts we will predict there will be
a major conflict between is Isel and
Hamas and the central Bankers will be
very active and greed is at the center
of it all and who uses these words
continuously that the world is greedy
that we should protect ourselves against
climate change that these evil axes must
come to an end that Financial currencies
should be coordinated who's the one
propag in this behind the scenes all the
time of course it is the Beast the Beast
yes Martin you're a conspiracy theorist
so the dragon is giving his power unto
the Beast yes and create enough turmoil
that the kings of the world will
eventually say let's give our power unto
the Beast yeah Wonder after him and
let's Implement his Mark the mark of my
ecclesiastical power is that I have
transferred the solemnity of the Sabbath
to Sunday yeah so if you keep my day
then you are keeping my law and
accepting my authority and you are
actually worshiping me that's it but if
you keep God's law and you keep his
Sabbath then you acknowledge his
authority and worship him that's a too
and if you want to do that I'll use the
Central Bank digital currency to cut
your existence short so to make it plain
it's a tool of the Beast aha but it's
not the mark of the beast well it's a
very interesting scenario people can
study this for weeks on end and put all
the intricacies together but I think
we've given basically the gist of what's
going on here these things are planned
of course and this whole issue about all
of this this Molten lava and the heat
that's going around and the reducing the
temperature or limiting it to
1.5° is all a load of nonsense yes yes
it is smoke being blown yes can you
divorce anything that we've talked about
from worship no all this comes back to
worship that's why Satan is standing
there because it will come back to
worship yes and they're trying to depict
him as evil but actually they worship
him yeah that's why they knite these
people that blatantly worship Satan well
the Chinese Communist party is rewriting
the Bible the 10-year project to rewrite
the Bible Quran and other sacred texts
is all part of Z Ying Ping's quest to
make the faithful serve the party rather
than God what kind of a philosophy is
that well that falls in at King of the
South secularism at atheism will it have
to go yes it has to come under the under
under the so the King of the North which
is the papacy will have to uh supersede
this right so somehow this system will
have to begin to
wobble and the interesting thing is can
they write rewrite the Bible and the
Quran they can rewrite it but it won't
be the it won't mean anything it won't
mean anything and especially the Bible
which is the inspired word of God uh you
can't rewrite that unless you want to be
part of the son of pedition so is this
maybe planned as well yeah do you think
the papacy will mind if the Bible is
Rewritten no because they've done it
already oh right they will rejoice right
so is this an ally to them sitting at
the same table or is it an enemy it
helps them a lot in a secret
2018 negotiation the Vatican agreed to
allow the Chinese Communist party to
select Catholic Bishops in China
supposedly in exchange for vague
reassurances of safety for some Catholic
congregations which were immediately
abrogated uh is there a tension between
religion and and China yeah that is a
big tension but there's also cooperation
okay now tell me Martin Islam that
adheres to the
Quran is it part of the King of the
South or King of the
North King of the North yes because it's
part of Babylon isn't it yeah it's part
of Babylon but who's the king pin in
Babylon the papacy the papacy so if the
papacy is the king pin and the whole
book Book of Revelation is dedicated to
its
minations then uh it goes to show that
the worship must be diverted towards him
right that's it do we see this in
climate change activities oh definitely
do we see this in politics politics
everything is starting to pull together
to that one point okay now Tibetan
Buddhists are attempting to stand up to
the CCP
coercion but Beijing counters that even
Pope Francis leader of the mighty
Catholic Church accepts their authority
over Church leadership do you think
that's true or is that uh all part
eyewash yeah it's all part of the plan
part of the game to make it seem as if
there is a conflict of
interests Martin the Bible
predicts that Protestant America will
give its power unto the Beast yes is
that a religious Alliance yes is
Protestant America a
Christian organization if they call
themselves Protestant America supposedly
yes supposedly church and state should
must be separated but if this is going
to happen church and state must come
together again right this is all part of
the
biblical historic continuous script
which is prophecy real prophecy
yeah so we must make sure that we see
these things
happening more Young Americans doomsday
prepping for 2024 election system not as
stable as we assumed does the world
realize that something's going down yes
and they are a buzz because they had
some um not so nice wakeup call the
previous were the pandemic the previous
years okay younger Americans appear to
be the ones preparing the most for a
disaster scenario ahead of
2024 with everything from Global
pandemics to upcoming presidential
election on their minds a poll from
finder.com earlier this year found that
39% of American
Millennials and 40% of janers reported
spending money on disaster prepping in
the last 12 months by contrast only 29%
of Americans in general spent money on
emergency
preparedness in my work I see younger
people worried about a repeat of a CO
type event the types of disruption it
can bring to daily life Southern
Illinois University anthropology
Professor Chad
Huddleston told Fox News digital the
corrup a virus pandemic seems to have
opened up a new market for preparedness
industry what they're really worried
about is political upheaval as well
maybe even a civil war that's it so
you've got the
candidates but it's possible that there
can be a very serious clash in this
election well they're they're working
very hard to achieve it so everything
seems to be ready for a big
explosion and Iran has just warned as
well as
turkey that they've had
enough and it's interesting how they
hype this religious aspect it's so
amazing to me I read that uh one of the
legislator in turkey's
Parliament just criticized
Israel and said that God would judge
them for what they were doing and
instantly Martin he got a heart attack
and dropped down in the
assembly they gave him CPR and rushed
him away but the idea
is you are doing this and they're
playing this both sides there's another
university in the United States that
just lost a basketball game by 108 to
something like six or something like
that a really massive
walkover and the LGBT crowd said it's
because of your Christian
legislation you see because you are
saying you know that God instituted a
man and a woman that's why you lost that
game like that isn't that ridiculous
it's exactly but like you said it's
picking up that aha you see you want to
do this and it's both ways you talk
against Israel they drop down with a
heart attack instant judgment from God
you lose a basketball game instant
judgment from God they they're using the
eelan dialectic and rubbing these two
philosophies against each other until
they explode and we I think we're not
far from
explosion right and in the meantime
we're talking about no buying no
selling and a 666 and we don't realize
that it's all about worship yes all
right well Martin how does Robert
Kennedy fit into the fry yes because
he's a presidential candidate for the
Democrats but um what is his philosophy
or what is his belief now it's
interesting he he doesn't have much of a
chance of
winning but uh his philosophy attracts
some people he is sort of a conservative
on the one side and liberal on the other
side he's got a foot in both in in both
camps right that's true because a lot of
the conservative right actually likes
what he especially through co co they
were very font of what he had to say
correct now some are saying that if he
stays in the run as it is now he can put
a dent into the Democrats polling
success yeah and that would favor the
Trump Camp so some say he should
actually step down but it's interesting
that he is staying there yeah but and
he's standing as an independent so that
will really give the Democrats yes if he
can if he can Garner a number of the
votes that will weaken the overall vote
for the Democrats that would help the
swing to the right what you talk about
so I'm a big uh fan of Carl Yung and we
had we share the same birthday so that's
a
synchronicity and uh so I heard you talk
about that Carl Young help you awaken
spiritually or kind of reconnect
spiritually can you talk a little bit
about
that H well first of all I had a I had a
I knew that I would I needed to have a
spiritual realignment and the 12 steps
are are
built to induce
a uh A Spiritual Awakening of one kind
or another you know very personalized
there's no cosmology there's no
religion um but there's you know there's
basically they encourage you to um they
they make they ease your path at finding
your own spiritual path your own
relationship with a god of whatever your
understanding is you you talk about uh
surrender I never understood what that
meant until I read Carl Young and
started to experience my unconscious and
you know he talks about that what we're
aware of is uh is just the tip of the
iceberg of who we really are and that
most of who we are is unconscious and
that to become enlightened isn't to
learn something new but is to make the
darkness conscious I was raised in a
very very deeply religious
setting um when whenever he was home he
would read us you know we'd all get in
the bed and he'd read us the Bible
stories oh I and I went to Catholic
schools I went to Jesuit schools I went
to the nuns um and I went to a quaker
school at one
point well Martin that just gives you an
idea of the spirituality and where it
comes from right yes um I think we can
say that we're not denigrating the man
no it's just an observation to see where
he's from all right so he was was raised
Catholic he was raised in Jesuit schools
he even went to the Quakers that is a
kind of holy flesh movement almost with
outpourings of and manifestations of the
holy spirit in adverted
commas and uh this is the spirituality
that they're talking about and the use
call Yung MH I know you've uh had
previous lectures on K Yung yes K Yung
received his Revelations under the
influence of
drugs and he he spoke to Spirit
entities and this is where their
spirituality comes from now to to make
this an issue of study and to introduce
that into your spiritual life is exactly
the same as the exercises of Lola yes
the spiritual for form exercise the
spiritual
formation and uh those
are ritualistic activities that you
perform often enhancing them with
substances that's why Many religious
systems actually can't function without
marijuana for example because they need
to open up a channel to a higher
Consciousness which is nothing less than
demon possession by the way if we talk
straight to talk yeah God doesn't want
that yeah uh if you want a relationship
with someone do you have to take drugs
in order to achieve it no unfortunately
that's the main thing that the world
tells you but if God wants you to not if
but God wants you to have a clear mind
when you decide for him or against him
you want to have a personal relationship
you want to walk with God you don't want
to sit in a circle smoking hashish in
order to have a
relationship because then you will have
a relationship with demons so that's
pretty straight talk but that's the way
it
is bottom line does spirituality come
into politics in a major way no matter
which side of the spectrum you're
sitting on definitely it's okay
unmistakable now some states like France
say no church and state must be totally
separate this comes from the French
Revolution of course yeah they almost
their religion is almost secularism
right now in the United States of
America this ideology of the French
Revolution was rigorously enforced in
the separation of church and state are
there voices that saying this has to go
yeah now France is still the hardcore
right it's interesting that Francis
Emmanuel macron got buffeted from all
sides in a row over
secularism Emanuel macron has been
accused of betraying the French Republic
after he took part in a Jewish ceremony
inside his official
residence in a country where the
separation of religion is itself a
religion the lighting of a Hanah candle
was immediately denounced by politicians
of both right and left because he said
now he's he's taking part in a religious
experience and that's not in line with
separation of church and state now he's
Jesuit trained isn't
he so you can't get away from it no
Kennedy was he Jesuit trained yes you
can't get away from it uh if you go to
Donald Trump's side are they Jesuit
trained yes yes on the other side are
they Jesuit trained everywhere
everywhere so is the Beast involved of
course yes the Beast is involved the
beast from the bottomless pit let's call
it by its name and the leader is the pop
son of ption yeah mtin why would it do
this is it to start scratching at the
surface for sure why is he visiting the
pope why is he doing all of these
religious affiliations all right now if
they should give that up and give their
power unto the Beast isn't that an end
of the separation of church and state y
are they going to do it yes aren 10
Kings going to give their power unto the
Beast yeah and are the 10 Kings the
powers of Europe and their Affiliates as
they have been expanding like the United
States and every other of those
countries yeah and actually as we've
shown most of them have already done it
okay warning for Biden admin as Europe
swings to the right and unfettered
migration threatens Western
values now the problem with the
migration is
twofold number one it is bringing
in people that will become dependent on
the state largely yeah particularly
initially but the other problem is
ideological yes now a lot of the riots
that are taking place are for example
Pro Hamas correct so do we bring in a
religious element there again sure I
mean that's a very good strategy all
right and then the other side says if
you say anything against Israel you drop
dead or you have to resign from your
university
positions and uh you have a big who are
is there a clash between two ideologies
yes that ailan dialectic is working
all right so can you divorce religion
from the migration issue no no so some
of these people that are moving to the
right in Europe are they also
criticizing the Quran yes now in Denmark
they were burning the Quran and they've
just brought out a law prohibiting that
so is religion in The Fray it's
everywhere it's it's not disconnected
from anything whether it be the
political the immigration the climate
change relig is everywhere okay now the
religious systems
uniting that would be Babylon right yeah
under the leadership of the papacy
that's that is the King of the North is
there a conflict between the King of the
North and secularism yes is there a
conflict between the King of the North
and the South then that's it correct
right
so Firebrand politician K Wilder's
surprising late November election
victory in the Netherlands has prompted
a political sea change and could alter
the European political landscape Wilders
the so-called Dutch Donald Trump seeks
to Cobble together a coalition to govern
the northern European country of nearly
18 million people there have been some
significant Telltale signs that parts of
Europe are shifting to a more
conservative political culture and they
mention uh Italy and Spain is moving in
that direction Sweden is moving in that
direction there seems to be a trend yes
definitely a religious Trend if you can
say it like that yes and at the same
time they they're trying to have peace
between moderate Islam and Western
culture and Greece is very interesting
in that aspect so there are talks
between turkey and Greece to cool down
the the sentiments after all they're
NATO countries yeah so very interesting
but the bottom line is there's a shift
to the right yeah and a shift to the
right in thinking means giving power
unto the beast that's what exactly mhm
that's what it means right that's what
it
means all right Martin so we saw Simon C
there in that picture from The Economist
and behind him was what's happening on
the world stage and he was keeping
people entertained right yeah on the one
side so do you think the entertainment
world will play a great part in swinging
the sentiment yeah we know it it is it's
Jesuit theater so do they do the
celebrities still have clout Yes
actually quite a lot what about this
Young Swift lady and her romance with an
American football star is that something
that everybody in the world is ooing at
and billions are flowing into coffers
yeah it's amazing what the entertainment
world can do right I well we've shown
numerous citations that it's probably
one of the strongest um tools that Satan
can use so if you have a rush of
entertainment World figures rushing to
the pope will that also change
Sentiments of course we have to they
have to get their um orders from
somewhere okay let's have a look during
his usual Wednesday General audience the
pope had an unexpected visit one with
Arnold
Schwarzenegger a great to be
you here and say thank you very much
forting we must communicate the import
is not only about climate change but
about how many people die every year
because of 7 million thank you very much
thank you meet thank you good to meet
you this is my wife good morning Holy
Father my
daughters three three married thank you
sop and my brother Frank good morning
Scarlet good morning sister and my
brother
father well thank you very much taking
time of your busy
day we grew up with your
film wow ready we
box oh yeah
ready what so great I I appreciate it so
much and for 11 years this is something
I've tried to do and you know you have
to go through all these different ways
and we did it a different way and and
the next thing I knew I was in Rome yeah
and my found
wanted to say thank you for everything
you're very
important not as important as you I I
don't know what what any of it means but
I know that I feel better wow um
because I feel like
somebody up there likes me that's the
best way I can put it
well Martin are the hero shipping the
pope yeah God is smiling at them because
they're going to the pope how do they
treat him what do they say to him that
is
amazing very important wonderful without
him the world would not be able to exist
the Bible calls him the son of ption
whom the Lord will destroy with the
brightness of his coming that's pretty
serious talk that is very serious talk
and he's he's the head of the Beast
system and the dragon gives him his
power Dragon sits behind it
okay proe Francis calls for end to
fossil fuels at cop 28 in
Dubai the pope threw his weight behind
calls for an end to fossil fuels in a
message delivered here at cop 28 now
they were arguing this way and that
way then they brought out a resolution
which was not very strong on fossil
fuels m
after all it's taking place in Dubai so
oil is a very important
issue and the great Glutton the United
States is guzzling all the oil not the
other nations not China who is importing
all of the our coal here out of South
Africa and burning it like crazy even
though it's the greatest polluter of
them all it's the United States that's
the Glutton and must Force the world to
accept one thing or another right yeah
very interesting
now of course they've just brought out
their final resolution and everybody's
clapping hands that there must be a
serious addressing of fossil fuels yeah
and the year that they mention is
2025 I find that interesting because
Alice a Bailey says that's the time when
there will be a
manifestation of the hierarchy in other
words Satan and his demons will manifest
the eles yeah according to LS Bailey
well according to the economist too ex
who was orchestrating the climate change
little computer there all the things the
devil little the dragon but he'll come
as an angel of Light right yeah he won't
look like that no
2024 the elections will take place
2025 and then you had that uh massive
document of over 900 pages of the
political yeah uh system what and what
the landscape will look like project
2025 project
2025 is Sunday legislation in there very
much not even an
uncertain um terms it's very well put
out in there
plon it says there it default to Sunday
default to Sunday it'll default to
Sunday whose Mark is that the Beast the
Beast so
the
cbdc the
666 digital system is that the mark of
the beast no it's a tool to implement
the mark of the beast okay because only
the Beast can tell us what its Mark is
and as we have said it has plainly said
that their Authority counts above the
Bible and the proof is moving the
Sabbath to the Sunday that's it
therefore by acknowledging their
Authority you are worshiping the Beast
it's an issue of worship and if they put
the economic squeeze on you and you
capitulate then you receive the mark on
the hand or in the forehead well if you
believe that they are right you have it
in the fored yeah but if you resist it
will you have turmoil oh for sure will
there be a time of trouble such as never
was what is the promise of God for that
time that he will protect those that
keep the command Commandments and have
the testimony of Jesus Christ it's very
plain in the Bible it's about the
Commandments of God here are those that
keep the Commandments of God and have
the testimony of Jesus here are those
that keep the Commandments of God and
have the right to the tree of life no
matter how Rome has tried to change
those verses and make them read
something else that's what they say
that's it okay so the man behind the
scene the one who without the world just
cannot
live is the beast power the
papacy now what we've consistently said
that the whole climate issue is a lot of
nonsense given the minuscule amount of
CO2 in the
atmosphere and what one little volcanic
eruption can do to CO2 which far
outweighs anything that's happening in
the world by the way are there numerous
eruptions yes currently mhm are there
numerous earthquakes currently yes is
that one of the signs of the last days
signs of the last days the Earth is
reeling against all of this all right
and what does real science say and not
science falsely
socalled real science says Martin it's
not climate change that's causing heat
waves this summer but no one wants to
explain why in the 19 1930s the
government's Heatwave index was four
times
higher interesting right government
researchers have been tracking heat
waves for more than a 100 years
according to data from the US climate
change Science Program which is made
available by the Environmental
Protection Agency the annual Heatwave
index for the contigous 48 states was
substantially higher in the
1930s than at any point in recent years
in some years in the 1930s it was four
times greater or even more Martin they
are talking nonsense yeah because at the
same time you'll hear now oh it's record
uh heat waves and all of that and then
you go look at the data and here you
have the graphs and you have the years
and you see where the Peaks really were
and this is an agenda and it's part okay
we've mentioned this many times before
there is some Str strange occurrences in
weather but I think a lot of it's
planned and manipulated well if they can
put a hanglider there and show what's
going to happen uh more than a decade
later then uh they can use their
facilities to change the climate that's
it and once again who's standing on that
picture the Devil he's controlling all
of and he has been studying this for
decades and he can sweep away the
Harvest as he did in the days of job and
we've said it at nausea and we're not
going to have to repeat it too often
again but lies are lies that's it and
the Bible says surely we have inherited
lies and the devil was a liar from the
beginning and he has given that power
unto the Beast who has been lying to us
from the beginning saying that salvation
runs through the system rather than
through Christ salvation runs through
their tradition rather than the word and
when that was exposed they introduced
The Counter Reformation which was based
on lies and people are swallowing the
lies of a false Messiah that is going to
come and an antichrist that's going to
be in a temple of stone when we're
building a spiritual Temple the whole
system is based on lies he was a liar
and his Advocates are liars yes they are
from their father the devil who is a
love liar from the
beginning all right so Martin when the
Central Bank digital currency comes into
effect that's not the mark of the beast
no it's got nothing to do with the
actual worship it's just a tool to
implement it to enforce it to get you to
do what they want now let's get these
gentlemen to tell us what their plans
are and the one final note I will uh
make is that if you think about the
benefits of digital money there are huge
potential gains you could have as I
argue in my book a potentially better
and some people might see it or a darker
world where the government decides that
units of central bank money can be used
to purchase some things but not other
things that it deems less desirable and
and will adhere to the law that is that
is what this platform will do um so if
somebody
says does something illegal then they
they will be suspended uh if they if
they do not do something illegal then um
they may that
we will try our best to avoid any any
kind of permanent bans unless someone
does something fundamentally illegal um
Elon I don't know we don't we're trying
we're just trying to stay true to the
Constitution of the United States in
unit in America and and the laws of the
country as decided by the citizens Net
Zero who would have thought that they
would impose fines if you didn't comply
so just like you Les in the latest
development we could be fined and or
criminalized if we don't go along with
the upgrades that they're forcing us
mainly at our own expense to make so say
for example you fall foul of regulations
to reduce your energy consumption you
could face up to a year in prison and
fines of up to
£15,000 or if you fail to submit the
correct information of what you're using
you could also be prosecuted for
provision of false information about
Energy Efficiency or for the obstruction
of an enforcement
Authority all right these are the
threatenings and the Rumblings of the
system uh does this mean they're going
to force you to do something yes so for
instance the Free
Speech King Alon musk also said that
they will have to are they doing
censorship according to the laws of the
land so once the law of the land changes
then they will censor accordingly
accordingly and so the the like the
other um guy in the beginning said the
digital
currency as is there to coarse you or to
force you they can decide do they want
can you use your money on certain things
or not and then like we've also seen
before if you don't adhere if your
carbon footprint are too big they can
switch off your money does Sunday become
part of the carbon footprint that's the
thing it is already in the uh um L out
to see and in the new one that the pope
so I suggest you start practicing so
that you no longer breathe on Sundays
yeah so that you don't have a carbon
footprint yeah that's how ridiculous
they are by the
way this kind of censorship and
coercion who's the master of it all
who's been practicing that for Millennia
yeah the papacy the papacy right do they
censor oh for sure and do they censor
truth the whole time the whole
Inquisition was brought about because of
this of censoring truth you weren't
allowed to quote the Bible you weren't
allowed to possess a Bible if you did
you were persecuted so if you believe
the Bible today what then then you're in
trouble because you're a fundamentalist
then you're a fundamentalist I'm so
proud I believe the Bible I'm so proud
that they will call me a fundamentalist
because they are
to every tenant of the word
absolutely Tik Tock pledges $1 million
at cop 28 to fight climate change
misinformation AS Global audiences on
Tik Tok engage in climate conversations
the platform acknowledges a rising risk
of
misinformation during cop 28 at Expo
City Dubai Ian Gil Global head of
sustainability at Tik Tok shared
insights about the platform's response
to the challenge Tik Tok has introduced
a one million initiative dedicated to
addressing climate
misinformation collaborating with
verified for climate a joint program of
the United Nations and purpose so are
they Pro climate change agendas or anti
definitely pro pro and they're they're
putting
money on the table in order to make sure
there's no misinformation so if we take
an for an example what happened during
the
pandemic this opposition voice was
totally silenced yes so what will happen
because The Narrative of the United
Nations with whom they are working is
definitely not the one that we've shown
earlier that uh science actually shows
there's nothing so if you show that
graph of the 1930s would that be
classified as misinformation definitely
Now isn't that amazing that somebody can
take historic facts and sweep them under
the table yeah now who's the expert in
that isn't it Rome as well exactly now
Martin if you say something long enough
people will become convinced that it's
actually the truth right you repeat a
lie over and over eventually it becomes
truth in the minds of people in the
minds yes so how many people actually
believe that this digital currency and
666 is associated with the mark of the
beast well
Millions all right let's have a look at
some of the barle players and see what
they say like one day in the future
everything will be traceable that's
right and that's you know this is where
I get this is where being raised an
Episcopalian and the book Book of
Revelations is going to as a Christian
you're going to read it this is where I
get scared because it's too similar to
the mark of the beast it's too similar
to exactly what it says you won't be
able to trade you won't be able to do
anything unless you have the mark unless
you bear the mark So what is that that
that in that term in the how is that
descri how's the mark of the beast
described in the
Bible we should read it cuz I think
you're on to something the mark of the
beast it's like you can't do anything
you can't sell I mean that's that's that
like if you remove the ability to trade
currency in a private way yeah you now
can you you are now controlled you are
now monitored it also causes all both
small and great both rich and poor both
free and slave to be marked on the right
hand or the forehead so that no one can
buy or sell unless he has the mark
shagma
shagma uh translated as mark of the
beast in re Revelation 13:16 can also
mean any Mark engraved in printed or
branded stamped money document or coin
the mark of the beast is interpreted
differently across the four main views
of Christian uh eschatology eschatology
now did you notice the fundamental flaw
in their argument
mhm nobody can buy or sell unless they
have the mark yes that's scripture
exactly so so buying and selling cannot
be the mark yes because you can only buy
and not buy and sell if you take the
mark so the Mark is nothing to do with
the buying and selling it's only a means
to implement the mark yes so they are
equating the buying and selling the
digital currency with the mark no
because that goes into effect
if you refuse to receive the mark yes so
and we must remember this Joe Rogan and
we're going to show the other ones as
well got huge audiences of millions of
people watching so they're very
influential so let's have a look at the
others movers and shakers like Glenn
Becker for example Nobody Knows the time
you know we're all told but I mean if
you haven't if you're a Christian and
you haven't at least thought
that
maybe there's a lot of Prophecy being
fulfilled here um maybe this is the time
um you know I talked to Pat earlier this
morning and he said I always thought it
would be more obvious if this is the
time you know the mark of the beast is
that cbdc I don't know what what is it
what it could be anything and he said I
always thought it would be more clear
but it's it's not uh maybe it becomes
more clear but you can tell the
difference between good and evil most
people can still do that although many
listen hour one of this broadcast um
many
cannot same mistake right same mistake
you see they
cannot and maybe they're ignorant
because I'm sure that a lot of people
are giving the truth to them I wish
somebody would give them the great
controversy well I think um Glenn
has um acknowledged that he's had
received it over 500 copies of it over
the past years well I I wish it would
read it I wish it would read it then you
will you you will put the puzzle
together the puzzle is very distinct
it's an issue of
worship and if it's an issue of
worship then it's also an issue of
obedience to the requirements of God yes
as opposed to the requirements of the
Beast and the Beast has to be in
Rebellion against God exactly and the
thing is that you know some of these
people like Glen just said everybody
must start realizing there's something
going on there's something going on and
a lot of the things that they try and
put together it makes sense but they
must just get the final part the cherry
on the top and then everything will make
sense and they can be very strong voices
for the
truth now Alex Jones has been in a lot
of trouble mhm and it's very interesting
that it gets back onto X when he was
banned
originally as long as he adheres to the
rules and the laws of the state right
yeah so let's listen to that and you can
take care of your family and and and
you're independent they have to destroy
all that because the rest of world
aspires to that instead they want
15minute cities Central Bank digital
currencies uh they want uh all of these
systems that track and Trace everything
you do in the social credit
scores and you ask again why would you
do that because it's all about breaking
our will they don't want people to
Aspire to open free societies yeah
there's a lot of waste there's decadence
There's issues but there's Freedom they
want to train us to live on carbon
rationing food rationing a very dystopic
World you'll own nothing you'll have
nothing and you'll be happy these are
quotes I have to say I I bet there are I
don't know how long into this we are
like I'm listening to this and even
myself I'm thinking I can't believe I'm
nodding along to Alex Jones and being
like you're absolutely right like what
what where are you wrong you have to
worship the Beast that can be seen by
all on Earth at the same time it
describes these big Holograms you got to
watch and worship and it tells you what
to do and it tells you how to live and
it says men become women and women
become men and children are set upon
their parents and there's nothing but
wickedness being invented and it
describes everything that's now
happening and says when they roll this
out you got to worship this world
government you got to worship the system
and do exactly what it says or it
doesn't let you buy and sell and and so
whether people believe in the Bible or
not believe in Revelation or not it is
now
manifesting I I don't see a lie in that
I don't think I am a Christian but I
don't think you need to be one uh to
arrive at exactly the same conclusion
they talk about the Beast they talk
about the worship of the
beast but they're concentrating on the
control yes which is just a method it's
just a method it's just part of the
other side there's two sides is actually
controlling this whole thing yes behind
you know the papacy sits behind it but
both
sides the globalists as they call them
and the other ones that seem to be the
heroes are all part of this whole thing
and they they miss the the central point
which is
worship and the Bible is very clear whom
you obey yeah that's the one who you are
actually paying homage to that's
worshiping so Martin if I could only put
it together but isn't it amazing that in
all these huge talk shows or podcasts
they're talking about the same thing
everywhere even in the news they're
talking about this so definitely we are
on in a place in history we where we
have not been before correct so just
because we said these people should all
get the great controversy if they don't
want to read it can we read a portion
for them let's read it for them the mark
of the beace when Sunday observance
shall be enforced by law
or will it be done under the opes of
religion and climate change oh for sure
definitely and the world shall be
enlightened concerning the obligation of
the true Sabbath then whoever shall
transgress the command of God to obey a
precept which has no higher authority
than that of Rome will thereby honor
popery above God he is paying homage to
Rome and the power which enforces the
instit stitution ordained by Rome is
worshiping the Beast and His Image as
men then reject the institution which
God has to declared to be the sign of
his authority and honor in instead that
which Rome has chosen as a token of her
Supremacy they will thereby accept the
sign of allegiance to Rome the mark of
the
beast and it is not until the issue is
thus plainly set before the people and
they are brought to choose between the
Commandments of God and the Commandments
of men that those who continue in
transgression will receive the mark of
the beast they don't know yet no so they
haven't received the mark of the beast
no but if it's plain and they begin to
understand it and they still decide for
the Beast then they receive the mark of
the beast so what does this tell us
there's still time there's still time we
must still preach we must preach louder
yeah and we must get to these people and
try and show them the truth all right we
continue poy is just what prophecy
declared that she should be the apostasy
of the latter times quoting to
Thessalonians 2 3 and 4 it is a part of
her policy to assume the character which
best accomplishes her purposes but
beneath the variable appearance of the
chameleon she conceals the invariable
Venom of the serpent we are not bound to
keep faith and Promises to Heretics she
declares shall this power whose record
for a thousand years is written in the
blood of the Saints be now acknowledged
as part of the Church of
Christ it's a very good question this is
what we are heading for because we see
it the
Antichrist they've written Jesus Christ
out of the Plan of Salvation yeah
they've put treasuries of Merit and
other such nonsense in the place thereof
Martin this is the issue and I wish
people would understand it but they
don't that's true and you see the thing
is Pope Francis is playing a very good
role as a chameleon he's a very good
chameleon and Catholicism has not lost
one ioto of its animosity against true
protestantism that's it so maybe we must
see how
traditional Catholics feel about this
because underneath the chameleon that he
portrays to the outside world this is
the true way that I'm sure the they the
pope feels as well it's a power from the
bottomless pit well here's the church
militant let's listen to what they have
to say the Catholic Church the human
Dimension has been overrun by the
Protestant heresy when we talk about the
church and nice that's actually what
we're talking about that large group of
Catholics who have joined themselves to
the lie that is protestantism
protestantism is a lie because it is a
heresy we've been hitting this theme all
week and heresies like sisms lead to
hell for the unrepentant here's the rub
every single last one of those beliefs
they get from Catholicism period they
didn't come up with those on their own
they belong to us we're happy to share
them just take them all when Martin
Luther and his heretical cohort were
walking out of the church they took a
few things with them those beliefs among
them and then over the centuries
Luther's followers have taken those
Catholic treasures and distorted them
almost beyond recognition in the area of
theology for example Protestants don't
have a clue about sacred scripture
although they all dance around like they
do they interpret it for themselves and
they fill in the blanks as they go along
essentially making it up what it creates
is an environment where instead of being
instructed by scripture you instruct it
Protestants impose their personal
beliefs on the texts and they twist them
to mean whatever they like the most
they're not a church they're normally
nothing more than a nonprofit
organization that meets once or twice a
week and occasionally gets something
correct in scripture but most of the
time makes a shipwreck of the Sacred
texts because they have denied the
authority of the Catholic Church who
gave the world the Bible it's our book
you don't take it and then get to tell
us what it means and then having denied
the authority of the church to correctly
interpret it even though again the
church produced it then they claim a
right which they do not possess the
ability to interpret scripture it denies
the efficacy of the sacraments most
especially the real presence of Christ
body blood soul and Divinity in the
Eucharist it twists and distorts sacred
scripture in the egotistical air of
telling congregations what they want to
hear we're not essentially all the same
meaning in essence they deny the church
and he who denies the church denies
Christ himself not a single book of the
Bible for example itself claims to be
inspired not one yet Protestants go on
and on about the Bible being inspired
well since the Bible itself doesn't even
claim that then why do they believe it
Martin I thought the Bible was God
breathed yes yeah and I thought it was
for correcting and teaching and well
obviously it was not inspired according
to the traditional catholic view well
the traditional catholic view is one
that negates the Bible and puts
tradition in its place so just for in
case people were still thinking oh but
they've changed they have not changed
we've seen it from the spirit of
Prophecy correct and only they may
interpret the Bible so we have the anti
Christ telling us what the Bible
actually is saying and saying it's not
inspired they the church is the inspired
portion well what he's saying is so
ridiculous and so distorted the Roman
Catholic Church never gave anybody the
Bible they were only good at removing it
yeah so but you see he has not a clue as
to what happened in history but you see
this is and if people go and watch the
the complete video because this is just
a small portion of that and that is the
true Catholic stance the true Catholic
position she has never changed she is a
chameleon the system the system and the
point is Martin the essence of the Bible
is righteousness by faith yeah and
righteousness by faith is part of the
third Angel's message and the third
Angel's message is do not accept the
mark of the beast because then you are
accepting a spous righteousness which
comes through rituals and traditions
rather than the unspotted righteousness
of Christ which is manifested by
obedience to all of God's Commandments
and that's our D of which they keep none
they changed
them in the movements now in progress in
the United States to secure for the
institutions and usages of the church
the support of the state Protestants are
following in the steps of papers Martin
this was written more than 100 years ago
MH but it's more true now than it has
ever
been N More they are opening the door
for the papacy to regain in Protestant
America the supremacy which she has lost
in the old world and that which gives
greater significance to this movement is
the fact that the principal object
contemplated is the enforcement of
Sunday
observance is it in LA yes yes is it in
Project
2025 yes which is supposedly a
Protestant um manif
manifest a custom which originated with
Rome and which she claims as a sign of
her Authority it is the spirit of the
papacy the spirit of conform to worldly
Customs the veneration for human
Traditions above the Commandments of God
that is permeating the Protestant
churches and leading them on to do the
same work of Sunday exaltation which the
papacy has done before them so Martin a
lot of the spirituality in the western
world has been lost yeah how easy do you
think it would be to sway sentiment to
bring it back well according to what's
happening in the world now I don't think
it's very difficult because everybody is
so tired of all the secularism that or
the conservative people are tired of all
the secularism and and they're using
movies and entertainment to do it like
the chosen for example which is largely
influenced by the church of latterday
saints that's it a Mormon movement where
brigam young said that the devil told
the truth about godhead I would not have
mother Eve Miss eating the forbidden
fruit for anything through the gift of
sin man can achieve godhood you see
those are incredible statements and
that's the leadership of that church yes
and it was involved through Joseph Smith
with the Jesuits through
diset and the whole issue is actually a
Jesuit run
organization and here in Time Square
they are the ones bringing back the
story and the sentiment associated with
the good old days when people were
Christian you see and that's the thing
we have to realize that the end movement
will be a religious one yes and it will
seem very good if you're not awake to
what's going on so let's see what they
are doing in Time
[Music]
Square
[Applause]
[Music]
how did they coordinate that if they are
just a Church how' they get everybody on
board to change their boards they've got
um quite some clout they have quite some
Cloud so by using these
sentiments they're taking us back to
that good old
time you see I was just
thinking yes there's a plan and Lucifer
sits behind all of this or
Satan but we must also take this
opportunity while the people are are in
this state of accepting these things
bring the truth to them now and let's
concentrate on the second coming of
Christ because all the emphasis is on
the first coming when he was a babe
yes let's draw our Focus completely the
second coming all right that brings us
to politics in the United
States James carille Christian National
ists like speaker Mike Johnson are a
bigger threat than
Al-Qaeda there you have the one side of
the issue Democratic strategist James
Carval sounded the alarm on new
Republican house Speaker Mike Johnson
saying he and other Christian
nationalists are a bigger threat to the
country than Al-Qaeda Mike Johnson and
what he believes is one of the greatest
threats we have today in the United
States Carval told mayor on Friday I
promise you I know these people you're
talking about Christian nationalists
mayor said absolutely carille responded
this is a bigger threat than Al-Qaeda to
this country now strange as this may
seem he actually has a
point he does not know what it means but
yes yes there is a point to this there
is a point because where can it lead to
it can lead to what the Bible has
predicted it can lead to a clash between
true
Christianity and supposed Christianity
under the leadership of the papacy
that's exactly what we've seen this
whole time now you've got this
Christianity this whole message this
everybody is hyped up because we're
getting Christian values back but it's
papacy values so let's have a listen to
what Mike Johnson actually has to say on
the issue
someone asked me today in the media they
said it's curious people are curious
what does Mike Johnson think about any
issue Under the Sun I said well go pick
up a Bible off your shelf and read it
that's that's my worldview that's what I
believe
for
mtin I have no doubt as to the sincerity
of the man that's why I said earlier
we don't judge the the
person but
unfortunately if it carries on like it
does it's a fulfillment of Prophecy and
he's calling it an exodus experience an
opening of the Red Sea he aligns himself
with
Aaron that means he's going to stand
shoulder toh shoulder with a Moses so
mtin who's Moses now is he Moses or is
he Aaron yeah yeah well he thought he
was Aaron maybe he's Moses but maybe the
president will be Moses and he will be
Aaron who knows but the pr of the matter
the bottom line is it's an exodus
experience that's it what was The Exodus
all about it wasn't it about the law of
God mhm let my people go so that they
can worship me in the
wilderness and wasn't he going to prove
them as to whether they would keep his
Commandments in the wilderness or not
that's it so was a question of obedience
to God as obedience to the system do we
have an antitype here oh for sure and
it's religious if you can see every
tentacle of religion is struck strung
onto this all right now if they can
carry on in this line they will March
towards the mark of the beast yes
unknowingly because they'll think it's
biblical so how important is it that we
Enlighten them that's what we are doing
in this show and we're asking people to
help us so
Martin this year has been a tumultuous
year once again yes I think it was
almost like a Midnight Cry
year and the
events will now not be a great
disappointment but will actually come to
culmination to the true one that we are
longing for we are heading for
the final
showdown with Malta yeah yes would you
agree I agree so Martin as we close off
this
year with uh all of these interesting
developments I think it's appropriate
that we read a
statement Joshua is represented as
pleading with the
angel are we engaged in the same work
are our supplications ascending To God
In Living Faith are we opening the door
of the heart to Jesus and closing every
means of entrance to
Satan are we daily obtaining a clearer
light and greater strength that we may
stand in Christ's
righteousness are we emptying our hearts
of all selfishness and cleansing them
Preparatory to receiving the latter rain
from
heaven now is the time when we are to
conf confess and forsake our sins that
they may go beforehand to judgment and
be blotted out now is the time to
cleanse ourselves from all filthiness of
the Flesh and spirit perfecting Holiness
and the fear of God it is dangerous to
delay this work Satan is even now
seeking by disasters upon sea and land
to seal the fate of as many as
possible what is the defense of the
people of God at this time it is a
living connection ction with
heaven and at that time shall Michael
stand up the great Prince which stands
for the children of thy people and there
shall be a time of trouble such as never
was
Martin when Michael stands
up then that is the end of the time of
Probation and then there will be a time
of trouble such as never was since there
was a nation even to that time and at
that time thy people shall be delivered
everyone that shall be found written in
the book that's the promise we must
cling to right and we've got that time
to do it right now by this we see the
importance of having our names written
in the Book of Life all whose names are
registered there will be delivered from
Satan's power is that another promise
promise and Christ will command that
their filthy garments be removed and
that they be clothed with his
righteousness is this part of the mark
of the beast and the warning against it
I'm 100% And they shall be mine says the
Lord of hosts in that day when I make up
my jewels and I will spare them as a man
spares his own son that serveth them in
the time of trouble Satan stirs up the
wicked and they encircle the people of
God to destroy them but he does not know
that pardon has been written opposite
their names in The Book Of Heaven
he does not know that the command has
been given take away the filthy garments
from them clothe them with change of
reignment and set a fair MIT upon their
heads Martin this is what we must do in
the time that we are heading towards I
believe that as well it's important to
know what's going on behind the scenes
it's important to know what's happening
on the stage of history but it's more
important that we get our hearts right
for the final events
and to bring the message to as many as
possible and it's important that we
understand the message because how can
you bring a message that you do not
understand that's true how can you
explain an issue if you do not
understand the issue how can you point
to the Commandments of God and the faith
of Jesus and the righteousness of Christ
if you don't know that that is the issue
true true so Martin this is our closing
statement for this year mhm
and who knows what the next one will
bring it will be tumultuous that we can
guarantee so
2024 I think will be
tumultuous we can expect that
2025 will be
fascinating if Alicea Bailey is correct
in her planning in her plans that were
manifested to her by automatic writing
so Martin we are living in the very
closing stages of Earth's
history and our principal question
should be am I right with God that's it
that's the
main and if we can answer that in the
affirmative then we have to ask
ourselves what can we do to save
Humanity from the
precipice we can only bring the truth to
them so you have to bring the truth
because you can only conquer error with
truth that's it so we need to preach the
truth we have
to introduce a
crescendo what has been a whimper must
become a loud cry yeah may God keep Us
Faithful may he fortify us may we put on
the whole armor of God and may we stand
in defense of Truth and righteousness
against all the Wilds of the devil let's
pray Heavenly
Father what a time to be living it is
not an easy time it's not a convenient
sofa to lie
on but it is a tumultuous time a time of
great interest a time of final
judgment Lord open Open Hearts and Minds
that they may understand the
issue and bring the power of the Holy
Spirit into the message because words by
themselves can convince no one without
the convicting power of the spirit we
might be preaching in vain so Lord pour
out your spirit according to your
promise in the latter reign in jesus'
name amen
amen
[Music]